what do you think is the biggest uh
mistake that most
Masters or amateur athletes make around
this time of year well it's the thinking
that you have to keep this perfect
string of workouts going right if you
get 80 percent of your week done if you
get three four days together strung
together done well and you miss a day
that's fine right we're all not going to
be a hundred percent on any of this I'm
never a hundred percent on any of this
let alone most of my athletes life gets
in the way right we all went pro in
something other than this Master's
Sports and so not judging ourselves not
worrying too much about missing a day
because the next day you're going to
come back more motivated more focused as
well as fresher and more recovered and
feel better doing it so don't look for
Perfection look for steady gradual
progress